all right I mean Peter the cutest
parents in bachelor nation like do you
feel the pressure to live up to this
love story a little bit I feel so
blessed you know to be able to call them
my parents they've been the most amazing
inspiration for me grown ups been the
best time ever and yeah I want what they
have
all right now guys I know you just did a
little walkthrough in the house of Peter
and you left some questions for the
ladies I think are you ready to vet some
women you have some high standards for
your boy I want the best for him of
course he knows a mom but I did leave
some questions in there that I think
that would give him a little bit of a
definition of what these women are all
about they're not easy questions but
they you know they will get to a point
which I'm looking forward to having that
daughter
I want that daughter to come home you
want that that solid woman for him I do
I really do he deserves it what type of
woman would you describe that Peter
again adventurous spontaneous when it's
loves flying I know probably be fine
but someone's sweet with a great heart
as well that's the most important thing
yeah now I have a question for you guys
I think pilot Pete still lives at home
is that true I do yeah and it's because
you you live that flying life but does
that mean if you get engaged is is the
lady moving in yes I have plans to fly
from the nest exactly yes my wings now
let me also ask you you guys got a lot
of fans support because of how
supportive you were of your son's sex
life of his time in the windmill you
cheered him on at that live taping and
it was wonderful I have to ask you an
embarrassing question how do you how do
you bring girls home if you live at home
no I am very lucky I'm very lucky so a
very supportive they are and I I brought
girls home and it's not weird in the
next morning I'll wake up and the girls
downstairs making breakfast with my mom
and they're chatting it up and that's
just the way it's been so I I know it's
not normal that this is about me
I also want to ask you guys you know
youyou kind of showed off your your
heritage and your upbringing how much of
your upbringing was like the Cuban side
the German side do you speak Spanish
fluently bla bla no poquito entiendo
todo um call me mama yeah yeah growing
up we yeah we we spoke Spanish my
grandmother that's pretty much all she
spoke and it's been a big part of her
upbringing he can carry himself very
well in Spanish you guys did that what
was the prayer no you got to make sure
not to eat the date food all right how
much flying is gonna be done pilot Pete
during this season are you gonna keep
flying or is dad gonna take over a
flight for you I don't know if you're
retired ya know I I'm hoping to do some
flying share that with my ladies that's
that's my first love and if I'm able to
share that with them I'll be very stoked
but yeah definitely off the work train
here for a little bit now my last
question for you guys you grew up I mean
just a few minutes from where we are at
the bachelor mansion you said you used
to try to sneak in does this mean did
you ever daydream about being bachelor
and did you guys ever think this could
happen life's crazy I swear I have vivid
memories of trying to hop over that
fence and sneak on here and this many
years later having this opportunity I'm
the most I'm the luckiest guy in the
world so and I have to admit something
now last year my season when he came out
when he was out in the mansion you and I
remember we went to the very very end
there and we got out of the car when all
the lights were on the first night and
we had to see it so we kind of sneaked
what we do tried to see we try to do
good there's so much security yeah that
we so we went over at the very cliff and
I'm like oh my God look at that any time
I see an airplane flying over I'm gonna
did you but did you ever like senior in
high school did you ever think I'll
maybe I'll be on the show I want to say
yes but no no honestly not really this
is like crazy what are the odds right
but hey guys surprise now this very very
surprised very surprised oh but it's
cool it's very cool I mean he's gonna
he's gonna knock it out he's a good boy
good guy great guy what was the most
important question that you wrote down
for these ladies well most of them
weren't important but the one that I
really wanted the most was what was your
favorite childhood memory I really
wanted to get to the root of their
childhood because that tells you a lot
of their upbringing and what they went
through and what was most memorable for
them at that time that carries in to
today what is your favorite childhood
memory that maybe speaks to you I'd
probably just say so we have our
favorite spot and my favorite spot in
the world we have a summer house in
upstate New York and that's just been
where all my family we've always
gathered every summer and there's a lot
of every you know I guess multiple years
of this but on my birthday is usually
you know the big fair going on the
fireworks and it's just I have all these
great memories of just my family
together and just you know my
grandparents that obviously miss like
crazy but I'm just family staying
together and enjoying those moments
summertime so I guess not constant
they're always we're there every summer
so it's it's very important to us yeah I
think if mom and dad don't like a woman
she might have a hard time being the one
for you definitely yeah but it's a I I
like that though we're very close and I
need someone that values family as much
as I value it so
[Music]